hi it's Michelle from Vlad luffing
beauty science here today I'm going to
be combining my love of skincare science
and sunscreen with my secret love of
arts and cross
sunscreen how much sunscreen do we
really need to use do you really need to
use a quarter teaspoon for your face
I'm sure you've asked yourself this a
few times because a quarter teaspoon is
really quite big and it's such a pain to
try to slow all that goop on your face
if it's thick and greasy then it takes
ages to put on and it's all greasy and
oily and if it's thin you have to go put
on so many layers to get it all onto
your face where does this quarter
teaspoon rule come from there are
actually a bunch of different estimates
for the amount of sunscreen that you
want on your skin for example the
Australian Cancer Council recommends
they use half a teaspoon for your face
head and neck the NHS from the UK
recommends two teaspoons of sunscreen if
you're just covering your head arms and
neck the American Academy of Dermatology
recommends one teaspoon of sunscreen for
your face and scalp some places even
recommend a full teaspoon for your face
alone and most of these recommendations
are quite confusing so they don't tell
you whether or not this includes your
ears or if it includes various other
bits of your face these calculations
come from the fact that sunscreen SPF is
tested at two milligrams of product per
square centimetre so if you want the
labelled SPF that appears on your
products packaging you'll need that
amount applying significantly under this
amount will give you uneven coverage
because your skin is quite bumpy and so
if you don't put on enough that most of
the sunscreen ends up in the valleys and
so the peaks of your skin the ridges
won't have enough sauntering covering
them they might even stick out and have
very little sunscreen and get more
damage so this two milligrams per square
centimeter measurement means that
depending on the size of your face how
many square centimeters it is the total
amount of sunscreen that you need is
going to vary the European Commission's
scientific committee on consumer safety
estimates that the 25th percentile of
women have a facial surface area of 565
centimetres squared this is based on a
study of women in Denmark and their
total head area and it
shoes that half of your head is the same
as your facial surface area so if we do
a little bit of maths that means that we
need two milligrams times 565 square
centimeters which gives us 1130
milligrams or 1.13 grams sunscreen has a
density of around one gram per mil so
this translates to one point one three
milks a quarter of a teaspoon is around
one point two five mils so that's a
round right if we assume that some at
the sunscreen around 10% ends up on your
fingers mineral sunscreen so in organic
sunscreens containing large amounts of
zinc oxide they're going to be a bit
denser so you can apply around one-fifth
less note that when we talk about
teaspoons here we're talking about
proper measuring teaspoons that are
either four point nine three or five
mils depending whether you're in the US
or the rest of the world a study found
that regular teaspoons the kind that you
eat with could hold anywhere between two
and a half and seven and a half mil
but obviously different people have
different size faces and so depending on
how big your face is or perhaps how
protruding your features are you going
to need a different amount of sunscreen
some people have tried to estimate the
size of their own faces in a few
different ways John Hsu from FutureGen
measured the length and width of his
face and multiplied them to give six
hundred and twenty square centimeters
our faces obviously aren't perfect
rectangles but since our faces are lumpy
so we've got nurses that come out for
example the extra area is meant to be
around the same as the area that is
those bits of the rectangle and so as an
estimate that sort of is valid a Korean
TV show used a grid that was printed on
plastic to cover a guy's face and they
worked out that he was 400 square
centimeters some people on reddit have
tried dividing their face up into
different rectangular zones and
approximating their face as an oval
which gave much lower values of around
360 square centimeters so these
estimates have inspired me to try and
find my own way of measuring it so I
went to this Priceline press event a
while ago and they gave me these rolls
of paper tape it's there in Priceline
pharmacy brand but basically they're a
generic version of three M's micro pool
my present nurses so I grew up around
this stuff thinking that this was normal
sticky tape this stuff is actually
really amazing for sticking on blisters
on your feet especially near your heel
and wrapping up paper cuts on your
fingers but today what I'm planning to
do with it is waste at all by covering
my face with it according to price line
this paper tape is 2 and 1/2 centimeters
by 9.1 meters which altogether gives us
over 2,000 square centimeters so I
really should have plenty to spare but I
think I've used some to stick over
clothing tags which were scratchy which
is another amazing use of it so if I run
out I might have to add some band-aids
to the mix so after I cover my face with
all of this tape what I'm gonna do is
take it off my face and then stick it on
this grid paper and then count the total
area that it covers so this way
hopefully I'll be able to measure more
accurately all the lumps and bumps on my
face with all these bits usually I love
mats and
hey I do things but sometimes empirical
research is a bit less of a headache
unless of course I'm like allergic to
the table something and it's gonna be a
bit of a pain counting all the squares
my face is pretty oily so I'm gonna have
to wash my face and blot it pretty
thoroughly and maybe even give it a
quick wipe down with some rubbing
alcohol but it's possible that if I go
too slowly then all my face oils will
come out and then unstick the tape and
everything gets ruined but that's a
problem for later Michelle let's mummify
my face so I know that watching me apply
tape on my face isn't the most exciting
thing to see so I'm gonna be treating
you guys to a dramatic reading of some
of my products Paula's Choice skin
perfecting 2% DHA lotion what it does
creates radiant even looking skin
soothes redness minimizes enlarged pores
our products are non-irritating
fragrance free and never animal tested
directions apply once or twice daily
after cleansing and toning apply a dime
sized amount over the entire face
including the eyes avoid the lower lash
line and eyelids do not rinse for
daytime always follow with a sunscreen
dear Claire's I never noticed the word
dear though supple preparation facial
toner moisturizing skin care program
dear Claire's
believes in simple skincare we use them
in products catered to your exact skin
type to produce the best results the
supple preparation facial toner is
formulated with a base of various
botanical extracts to balance the skin's
pH level and provide full nourishment to
the skin it contains various ingredients
such as lipid or and beta glucan which
provide deep hydration and help prepare
the skin absorb following products
better and boost their effectiveness
nutri biotic where science works
naturally pharmaceutical grade ascorbic
acid 100% pure vitamin C crystalline
powder dietary supplement neutral biotic
ascorbic acid is 100% pharmaceutical
grade vitamin C an essential nutrient
beneficial to the body's overall health
this highly soluble form of vitamin C
provides antioxidant protection to the
immune system
[Music]
I've gone off and counted all the
squares then it worked out to be 381
square centimeters this converts to not
0.76 mils of sunscreen for my face to
get 2 milligrams per square centimeter
which is about 60% of a quarter of a
teaspoon so somewhere between half a
teaspoon and two thirds I'm converting
all of these two quarter teaspoons
because that's the most common small
measuring spoon that people tend to have
I realized that I also apply sunscreen
to this area between my chin and where
it starts to turn into my neck and I
also measured that part using the tape
method it worked out to be 75 square
centimeters which takes the total up to
about 3/4 of 1/4 TSP I also apply
sunscreen with these three fingers which
works out to be 30 square centimeters
according to my tape method that takes
it up to about a bit over three-quarters
of a quarter teaspoon obviously this
measurement is a bit flawed because I
probably end up with 10 layers of
sunscreen on these fingers but it's
probably about as good of an
approximation as I'm going to get I've
also been meaning to wear sunscreen more
on my neck and my décolleté which turn
out to be a hundred and forty four and
two hundred and eighty square
centimeters respectively so this area
converts to about two thirds of a
quarter teaspoon if you want to try this
experiment at home I've put links to the
paper tape and the grid paper used in
the caption make sure that you print out
the grid as actual size rather than fit
to page which makes it a bit smaller
thanks for watching my video if you
liked this sort of video please
subscribe to my channel you can also
check out my blog which has lots of
stuff on science and beauty and you can
also follow me on Instagram and Facebook
see you next time
[Music]